i have seen way too many bias sponsored
reviews on this msi creator z16 so today
let's get honest and talk about the good
and the bad and if this is the ultimate
16-inch laptop for creatives like myself
and many of you guys but first i need to
give a thank you to microcenter for
sending this over for review micro
center has 25 stores nationwide with an
impressive variety of electronics from
gaming vr computer parts like processors
graphics and everything else needed to
build a pc they also have a huge variety
of desktops laptops and all the
accessories that you need not only that
but also highly trained staff and low
prices or use the link down below to
view the creator z16 at microcenter.com
they are also giving away a free 240
gigabyte ssd to new customers get all
the info in the link in the video
description right out of the gate i was
interested in this laptop because of the
intel 11th generation 45 watt rated
processor that is based on a 10
nanometer design we've been waiting for
these ships since 2016 2017 or so and we
finally have them so i want to see how
well they perform but as far as the
laptop itself i wasn't expecting that
much i actually had my very first laptop
for creative purposes photo editing
video editing was an msi and it was a
great bang for the buck laptop but it
did have a lot of flaws with this thing
i was surprised right away when i took
it out of the box because of how well
built it is now the older ones were
aluminum but they were very thin
aluminum where this thing is super solid
there's no chassis flex
even if you open this thing up it is
super sturdy now with that it is a
little bit on the heavier side you're
looking at about five pounds compared to
you know four or four and a half so that
is noticeable but i would definitely
take that
because of the extra durability just how
well it is designed now everything else
is nice about it the keyboard it feels
great i have no complaints trackpad
accurate smooth it is a diving board
design so if you're clicking above the
halfway point it is tougher to click i
ended up just tapping for that and one
very interesting thing with it is not
only do we have a fingerprint scanner
that is not built into the power button
for some reason but with that we also
have windows hello which i absolutely
love so not a lot of laptops offer you
both options now another thing that
surprised me is the fact the display
lays down pretty much flat uh maybe even
a little bit more than that now taking a
look at the bottom and the sides we see
a ton of vents which this laptop really
needs along with speakers at the bottom
which we'll also talk about that is a
nice positive and then on the sides we
have a big variety of ports we have two
thunderbolt 4 ports two usb a's which is
nice to have even if this thing is
pretty thin and they are the full speed
10 gigabit per second not the five and
then we also have a micro sd card slot
now this is interesting because this is
a uhs three and i don't even know if we
have uhs three cards yet but it is gonna
be future proof uh personally though i
wish it was a full-size sd card you can
always get an adapter for the micros but
you can't go larger so i don't really
know what they were thinking as far as
putting that in there and then as far as
power we do have a full-size barrel plug
because this thing does need a good
amount of power now back to the speakers
i have to say that these are the best
speakers i've ever heard in a windows
laptop there are four separate drivers
they get loud they have good bass i was
honestly shocked by how well they
sounded my previous msi sounded terrible
it was bad and many laptops like the
dells and say the razers they've gotten
a little better but they still sound bad
but this thing
was awesome let's go ahead and see how
it compares to the 16-inch macbook pro
that has the best speakers in any laptop
by far
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below it is
actually louder if you have it placed on
top of a desk because they do fire down
and then bounce up and if there's not a
ton of frequencies it actually could
sound better like with
instrumental stuff like that with just
voices once you have a lot of different
sounds it does fall behind the macbook
pros and that has six speakers that are
well tuned but overall man i was really
really impressed now as far as the
cameras and the microphones we have a
720p webcam it looks okay you clearly
see the person there are a lot of
compression artifacts to denoise it
but it's about average now the
microphones on the other hand they don't
have a lot of bass pickup but they are
very clear so the people on the other
side will be able to understand what
you're saying now before we get into the
performance and my biggest complaint
let's talk about a couple more positives
the first one being the ssd i'm glad i
tested it out because it is a pcr
express 4 and it runs super fast we have
read speeds of 5 500 and around 4 300
write speeds the performance is
incredible and this is gonna make a
difference when we start talking about
real world performance and the next
thing that really surprised me was the
display and msi talks a lot about it on
the website and now i can see why it is
awesome right between 4k and 1080p
that's great for battery life and also
for windows scaling
not only that but each one is factory
calibrated so the colors looked pretty
much identical to my macbook pro the
closest i have seen it gets nice and
bright reflectivity is a little bit
higher than macbook pro but not bad
and with that it supports dci p3 colors
so the colors look awesome great for
color grading and on top of that what's
something that my mac pro can do is the
display is a 120 hertz panel so
refresher is great nice and smooth and
then if you want to do some gaming with
that rtx graphics card you'll be able to
enjoy the higher refresh rates so good
job msi you killed it with this display
now inside of this machine is the tiger
lake 11th generation a 10 nanometer
processor this is the i7 8 cores going
up to 4.6 gigahertz so finally we have
that chip so how well does it do well
i'll overall let you guys know it's
pretty good i was pretty surprised and
in speedometer 2.0 browser benchmark it
scored pretty much 190 that is the
highest i have seen in any machine other
than the m1 macbook pros which
absolutely kill it in this so as far as
snappiness it is amazing and that makes
sense because this chip it literally
scales up its wattage and frequency all
the time it wants to maximize
performance and so i see it ramping up
all the time which we'll talk about but
as far as geekbench the performance is
also really good we have a single core
of 1400 and a multi-core of 7
800. now that is really impressive it's
great job beating out the m1 by a little
bit there but what i was interested in
is will this machine still be able to
perform that well
when you unplug it a lot of machines
slow down now this one did slow down but
not by that much by about 12 13
as far as the cpu so that is definitely
acceptable when you're not feeding it uh
power now of course macbooks they don't
slow down but i've seen some machines
that go down like 50 in power it is
terrible now when you're maxing out the
cpus like in cinebench i got a score of
10
300 that is about 20 percent better than
the 16-inch macbook pro that has an 8
core i9 processor remember this is the
i7 uh the i9 would get a little bit more
than this but not much because of
thermal throttling but that still is a
great improvement going down to 10
nanometers now with that we also hit 55
watts of power usage it actually doesn't
let it spike up higher to like say 60 70
like on a macbook so it is limiting it
but it does hit that really quickly
along with really high temperatures
almost instantly it ends up heating up
to 96 97 degrees so this 1080 nanometer
isn't really helping that much that's
because intel just is trying to get as
much performance as they can they have a
lot of competition with amd and with
apple as far as graphics this thing has
an rtx 3060 built in with six gigabytes
of video memory now first i thought it's
going to be limiting i thought maybe
they should have put in something better
but after testing it out i think it's
actually a really nice balance and other
laptops have other limitations as well
and the performance is pretty dang good
now as far as the cuda performance in
geekbench it got a really high 94 000.
that is a killer score so this graphics
are performing well but once again how
well does it perform when you unplug it
i've seen some go from 100 000 or more
down to 35 but thankfully msi is not
limiting it much and it actually got a
score of 83 000 so once again it's about
12 13 of a performance drop which is
definitely acceptable and you're going
to get most of your performance when
you're on battery power now what does
all of this mean in the real world well
as far as photo editing i have to say
that other than my mac pro i have not
seen anything go this fast and that mac
pro is about 15 grand switching through
photos was super quick very snappy
faster than the m1 and the same thing
with using brushes very very quick now i
think that's because one that ssd is
extremely fast and then two um it has
really good performance with the acre
processor and it's scaling up all the
time now one thing that was annoying is
even when i'm just switching photos the
fans are constantly spinning up
constantly spinning up and even
sometimes during web browsing and so
with this good performance i was like
maybe i should just slow it down a
little bit so i lowered the performance
setting in windows but didn't matter it
still kept running at really high
performance but also having those
annoying fans now as far as exporting
our standard 50 raw image test this
thing did it in a minute and 59 seconds
it is incredibly fast this laptop is
just great for photo editing now what
about on the other side for video
editing well i started playing back some
h.265 footage with some effects some
luts film grain and it had no issues
whatsoever now not only that only about
18
of the graphics card was being utilized
so there's tons of overhead so after
dealing some video editing i saw that
this gpu is more than good enough unless
you're doing like 8k footage or crazy
multi-camera raw stuff i don't think you
need a 30-70 or a 80. now when i
exported this project i was also quite
surprised it took a minute and 54
seconds to export my five minute project
so once again super quick beating out
the previous macbook pro 16 inch still a
bit slower than the new m1 with the
update but that is incredible for a five
minute project now overall i have a lot
of good things to say other than the fan
noise and realistically i don't know
what you could do you could slow it down
and i probably would slow it down but
then you start losing the benefits of
intel 11 gen and all the extra
performance and smoothness that you get
you'll kind of go back to a previous
processor if you don't want to deal with
the fan noise and the heat and of course
with that high wattage and with those
high boost clocks it just keeps coming
out so like half the time when i'm using
this the fan is kicking up and down and
to me that is just really really
annoying um but a lot of windows do
laptops do that you know especially if
you're trying to push them to the limit
so if you're okay with that
how does this compare to the competition
well with the dell you do get an oled
screen for the same price point or
slightly more but the graphics card is a
lot weaker
so because of that and because this is a
120 hertz screen that is calibrated and
great and overall it's a good package i
would recommend it if you're looking for
a windows laptop with a screen to size
as long as you're either going to tweak
the fans or maybe you know not care
about that so once again thank you for
micro center for sending it over if you
guys want to see us compare it to say a
16 inch macro pro or an m1 how that
competes with the 11th gen let us know
and click that subscribe button above
and check out one of those great videos
right over there that's been max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]